im september wissen sie ist
bundestagswahl und alle experten rechnen
am ende mit schwarz grün aber vielleicht
kommt ja auch r2 g klingt nach star wars
meint aber rot rot grün könnte das
kommen und kann man das wollen jetzt wo
die linkspartei eine neue führung hat
janine wissler und susanne hennig welt
so gerade beim parteitag in berlin
frisch gewählt eine eher normal links
die andere volles brett links wobei so
gemäßigt ist vorher nicht wer so auch
nicht hier zum beispiel eine erfrischend
radikale idee ich werbe dafür dass wir
die cdu/csu aus der bundesrepublik aus
der bundesregierung vertreiben die union
aus der regierung vertreiben
dafür hat die cdu doch schon armin
laschet wahren freundschaft
beziehungsweise makler versprecher von
hier aber ist ein gutes stichwort denn
ihre kollegin frau wissler war bis
neulich mitglied bei marx 21
das sind trotzkisten die vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet werden
außerdem war sie bei der sozialistischen
linken die für setzte steht wie zitat
die ddr war der legitimen versuch auf
deutschem boden eine alternative zum
kapitalismus aufzubauen
auch ein standpunkt und in ihrer
freizeit da packt dich an ihnen gerne
es geht nicht nur um ein größeres stück
vom kuchen es geht um die bäckerei es
geht ums ganze
ja janine wissler will die ganze
bäckerei enteignen
in umfragen liegt die linkspartei
übrigens zwischen sieben und neun
prozent das entspricht eher einem
angebissenen rosinenbrötchen dabei
werden die kernthemen der linken in der
korona krise sogar wichtiger es gibt
weder über eine million
langzeitarbeitslose so viel wie seit
fünf jahren nicht mehr
linke ideen wie die solidarische
mindestrente kriegen werden gar nicht so
verkehrt trotzdem wird rot rot grün am
ende nicht kommen warum wie immer wegen
außenpolitik die linken lehnen jede art
von bundeswehreinsätzen strikt ab ja
steht auch so im parteiprogramm und wenn
sie mal wissen wollen wie man seine
karriere in der linkspartei
immer durchs klo spült es reicht dieser
satz ich werbe dafür die vereinten
nationen zu stärken und in ihren
friedensmissionen sie in ihrer arbeit zu
unterstützen blauhelm friedensmission
kriegstreiber matthias höhn
denn da müssen sie sich nicht mehr
merken durchgefallen bei der wahl zum
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden raus
retuschiert aus allen fotos der
linkspartei unter anderem war der
gleiche moralische standards im umgang
mit staaten fordert und jetzt kommt auch
mit russland ist der verräter ihre seit
wann ist es erlaubt russland zu
kritisieren
russland ist mit friedensmacht egal zu
dagegen geführt von der us regierung mit
ihrem gefährlichen säbelrasseln und kann
von nationen wie russland und china und
und ist der aggressor ganz genau
ja klingt wie ddr-fernsehen von 1985 war
aber von letztem sonntag
verblüffend natürlich kann und muss man
die nato für vieles kritisieren es recht
die usa für ihren drohnenkrieg und so
das macht den putin ja nicht zu dem
friedensengel oder krieg in der ost
ukraine bomben auf syrien auftragsmorde
mitten in berlin und so gut wie kein
kritisches wort von der linkspartei
genau wie beim fall navalny ja da muss
man sich nicht wundern wenn am ende
wieder keine rot-rot- grüne regierung
zustande kommt schade schade eigentlich
denn umverteilung von oben nach unten
der doch eine ganz schöne abwechslung
windig ja ich fürchte die linkspartei
muss sich ein paar unangenehme
wahrheiten anhören genau dafür haben wir
sogar einen kollegen zum parteitag
hingeschickt
mein name ist alex kuprecht ich wollte
erst mal sagen 'nein susanne glückwunsch
ihr seid für mich jetzt schon die besten
linken-vorsitzenden seither wie hießen
die beiden noch davor ist ja auch egal
eine war ich so ich habe eigentlich nur
ein ganz kurzes referat vorbereitet
arbeitstitel warum ist die linke bei der
bundestagswahl garantiert wieder
gnadenlos verpackt ist ein bisschen
ironisch formuliert
na ja spaß muss sein
warum war das wieder nix wegen eurer
russland psychose wirklich bis zum arzt
wer jede kritik an diese man verbietet
und sich gleichzeitig friedenspartei
nennt der shuccle sorry vielleicht ist
euch das noch gar nicht aufgefallen aber
in seinem land sind ganz viele sehr arme
nur er und eine handvoll baten ist
reicher als gott das ist das gegenteil
von sozialismus faustregel wenn einer in
seinem büro acht meter hohe türen aus
purem gold hat ist auch kein linker ich
meine jetzt guckt euch doch nur mal
seine zwielichtigen kumpel an weil sie
doch schon alles und der typ hat die
krimmer und nicht wieder eingegliedert
daten geklaut
da braucht er jetzt auch gar nicht so
verlegen auf eure handys zu glotzen das
sind tatsachen
wer diesen mann kritisiert ist kein
kriegstreiber sondern verfügt über ein
funktionierendes gehirn und deshalb mein
tipp ist außenpolitik
es gibt kein paralleluniversum in dem
die linkspartei jemals den außenminister
stellen wird kümmert euch gefällt es um
eure kernkompetenz deutschen millionären
was wegnehmen wenn ihr das macht the
dream könnt ihr im herbst locker neun
prozent mindestens 8 mio
na ja und ich soll nicht sagen
draußen beim catering gibt soljanka und
bord
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbole bei uns im neuen studio gefunden
lumina die freimaurer staatsführung ist
alles dabei dann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen strippenzieher bekannt
geben dass so viele abonnenten auf
youtube also ich würde mich ran halten